foreign
you've heard of Bible accurate Angels
but what about Bible accurate demons
you'll be familiar with them from pop
culture but demons in the Bible that's a
murky subject for example where does
Satan really come from who came before
him welcome to the realm of evil spirits
fallen angels and ancient gods where the
boundaries of Good and Evil are not as
clear-cut as you'd expect this is an A
to Z of biblical demons
[Music]
I suppose I ought to get something clear
what even is a demon in its broader
sense a demon is an evil spirit a
supernatural being that's up to no good
demons appear across all world religions
in one way or another but the demons
will be exploring are from the Bible the
sacred text that plays a key role in
Christianity and to some extent Judaism
and Islam the Bible is made up of two
halves the Old Testament ancient Jewish
writings about the history of Israel and
the New Testament early Christian texts
about the life of Jesus now not every
letter has a suitable demonic
counterpart so sometimes I'll have to
get creative with the term biblical from
books that didn't make it into the Bible
known as the Apocrypha to The Wider
world of demonology inspired by these
religious texts but enough caveating and
demons blaming it's time to learn our
ABCs starting with a for asmodius as
modius is from The Book of Tobit it's a
strange story not included in all
versions of the Bible in one tale
asmodeus falls in love with a woman
called Sarah but Sarah is already
betrothed in a fit of jealous rage as
Modia slays the groom and repeats this
every time Sarah remarries seven times
no less as modius is eventually Banished
with an unusual spell the heart and
liver of a fish are placed onto a bed of
burning hot Embers the smoke it produces
smells so bad that the demon flees to
the deserts of Egypt Sarah moves on to
her eighth husband and lives happily
ever after B is for Balia Balia never
chose the demon life the demon life
chose him the word Belial appears
throughout the Old Testament but not as
the name of a demon instead the Hebrew
word for wickedness over time people
began to read this word as a name it's
not clear why exactly but baleau became
Bailey owl and puff a demon was born
this newly created demon appears
throughout the Dead Sea Scrolls a group
of Jewish writings found in pots beside
the Dead Sea in the amazingly named War
of the sons of Light against the sons of
Darkness Belial commands a vast Legion
of evil its real Lord of the Rings stuff
shame it never got included in the Bible
this version of balio offers the
blueprint for Satan from the New
Testament more on that demon later from
a Hebrew word that meant wickedness to
the Demonic embodiment of wickedness
itself Belial has had a surprising
origin story
C is for kemosh one person's deity is
another person's demon kemosh appears in
the Old Testament and was the chief god
of the moabites now a core biblical
belief is that there is only one God the
god of Israel so having another God in
the picture simply won't do kemosh
became the victim of a Biblical smear
campaign his worst crime an apparent
appetite for Human Sacrifice especially
children outside the Bible kemosh is far
less bloodthirsty he appears on this the
meshistele a carved Stone dating to 840
BC it was made by King mesha of Moab to
honor kemosh the god kindly gave them
Victory against their Rivals including
Israel this rock was a way of saying
thanks
D is for Dagon Dagon is another Pagan
God from the Old Testament he was the
god of wealth and prosperity and for
some reason was depicted as a mermaid a
reference to Lost Treasure maybe I say
this as Dagon appears in an episode
featuring The Ark of the Covenant a
golden box that supposedly housed the
Ten Commandments in the story The Ark is
stolen by the Philistines and is placed
at an altar to Dagon being the biblical
super weapon that it is the ark destroys
the statue and causes a deadly plague it
was returned shortly after
e is for exorcism mixing it up now a key
part of studying demons is learning how
to get rid of them a process known as
exorcism in the New Testament many of
Jesus's Miracles are exorcisms in one
story Jesus encounters a man living in a
cave inside him are not one but several
demons when asked their name they
respond Legion for we are many realizing
that they're about to be forcibly
ejected from their host the demons
persuade Jesus not to be destroyed Jesus
kindly agrees to transfer them into a
nearby herd of pigs which then run off a
nearby Cliff to their death this story
establishes a quirky tradition in modern
day exorcism asking a demon its name
apparently being on first name basis
helps banish them F is for fallen angel
another key word in demonology a fallen
angel is a good spirit that has been
corrupted the idea of the Fallen Angel
doesn't really appear in the Bible but
it is common in those apocryphal books
like The Book of Enoch it's all about a
group of angels called the Watchers who
visit Earth One day things take a turn
when they start falling in love with
human women who then give birth to a
monstrous race of giants called Nephilim
it's another great story that's
apparently too spicy for the Bible the
myth of the Fallen Angel really
influenced Christian writers and works
of fiction Like Paradise Lost It gave
rise to the figure of Lucifer God's
right-hand Angel who went rogue
G is for grimoire a grimoire is an
occult textbook full of magical spells
dark incantations and of course demons
one of the most famous is the Lesser key
of Solomon a comprehensive compendium of
demons it's a staple of demonology today
as it contains advice on how to summon
them like gab a prince of Hell who is
the patron demon of philosophy conjugap
to get help with learning the
differences between Plato and Aristotle
grimoires are not biblical per se but
many demons that appear in them do stem
from the Bible like the demon Belial
from before who is described as having a
comely voice
H is for Hades you may have heard of
Hades from Greek mythology but it
appears in biblical mythology too in the
New Testament Hades is the underworld a
realm of fire and brimstone demons and
sinners when our Spirits are not on the
surface World harassing human women or
leading Legions of Darkness therein
Hades blowing off some steam it's very
different to the old testament's version
of the underworld a gloomy Chasm called
shayol All Souls go here regardless of
whether you've been good or bad I is for
IPOs finding a biblical demon with a
letter I is a challenge but I've settled
on epos IPOs is a little strange looking
it has the head of a goose the body of a
lion and the feet of a chicken you can
find him in the Lesser key of Solomon a
demonic grimoire according to his entry
IPOs is one of the 16 Dukes of hell and
has this rather Splendid seal he knows
all things past present and future
J is for Jezebel J is another difficult
letter for biblical demons especially as
this letter doesn't technically exist in
either language the Bible was written in
Hebrew or Greek Jezebel is a character
from the Old Testament the wicked wife
of King Ahab she isn't a demon but there
is a demon in her name ba'al the lord of
the Underworld the name Jezebel is from
the Hebrew phrase Isabel or where is Bal
a prayer used at ancient funerals to
encourage battle to claim The Souls of
the deceased this demonic name might
explain why Jezebel is a villain in the
biblical story for her various crimes
including bowel worship she gets
defenestrated AKA thrown out of a window
Jezebel may not be a demon but if
there's an opportunity to talk about
levantine death Gods I'll take it K is
for cacabiel kocabiel is one of our
fallen angels from The Book of Enoch
this Angel is responsible for corrupting
humans with the Dark Art of stargazing
kokabial teaches the people astronomy
apparently that's a bad thing maybe it's
because the sky was seen as the realm of
God and shouldn't be the subject of
scientific study kocabiel later appears
in the Kabbalah a series of Jewish
mystical texts but now he's a good guy
his knowledge of celestial bodies is
regarded as a worthy thing to teach
which is a kokabiel angel or demon L is
for Lilith the demon s Lilith is perhaps
the oldest one on this list she appears
in the old testament's book of Isaiah
lurking in a ruined Town Lilith is
surrounded by creatures of the desert
jackals owls and goats but she goes back
way further than this to a Mesopotamian
demon s called lelitu a shadowy being
who prowls the night references to her
reach back to the Epic of Gilgamesh the
world's first written story Lilith's
name also appears in Old Pottery this is
an incantation Bowl along the side are
prayers to be read aloud prayers that
trap demons in the center is a figure
who's been ensnared by the bowl
many believe that this is Lilith
M is for mastema we're Midway through
the alphabet and what better way to
celebrate this Milestone than with
mastema the demon of persecution mastema
is from the book of jubilees again
another apocryphal book those bad
biblical texts certainly contain the
juiciest demonic law his job is to
punish people but strangely mastema gets
his orders from God whether that be
sending plagues to wreak havoc to
torturing folks who may or may not
deserve it he's kind of like a Divine
Hitman mastema blurs the lines between
Angel and Demon and what does this say
about God he not only allows demons to
exist but actively uses them to carry
out his punishments maybe demons aren't
so evil after all n is for Nephilim the
Nephilim our race of demonic Giants in
the old testament's Book of Numbers they
are so big that people look like
grasshoppers in comparison the Nephilim
also appear in the Apocrypha enter our
old friend The Book of Enoch which
explores how they came to be in the
story the Nephilim are the cursed
offspring of fallen angels and humans
and go about causing trouble on Earth at
450 feet tall they become a very big
problem and so God decides to wipe them
out with a big flood oh well it was fun
while it lasted the Nephilim are an
enigmatic Bunch for sure and not much
else is known about them O is for orneas
ornias is a demon from one of the oldest
grimoires in existence The Testament of
Solomon despite the name it was not
written by the biblical King Solomon
it's a bizarre book especially as it's
about how King Solomon was a secret
Demon Slayer his first assignment is to
deal with onias he's been harassing a
man by stealing his money and draining
his life energy classic demon stuff
Solomon traps orneas by sealing him with
a magical ring he then goes around
collecting more demons it's a Biblical
precursor to the Ghostbusters franchise
none of King Solomon's demon busting
exploits are in the Bible by the way
this story is biblical fan fiction at
its finest
P is for pseudo-christos we're back in
the New Testament to talk lies deceit
and false Messiahs that's what
pseudo-christos means in Greek false
Messiah you don't have to be a Biblical
historian to know that Christians
believe in one Messiah Jesus but there
are others who claim to be divine others
that will deceive unwary followers
they're hard to spot like a wolf in
sheep's clothing one of these false
Messiahs is quite literally that in the
apocalyptic Book of Revelation the
Antichrist takes the form of a little
sheep monster just with a few more horns
his job is to hail the arrival of the
Beast and get everyone to believe that
somehow this creature isn't evil Q is
for keteb we're back in the Old
Testament with keteb the demon of
disease or maybe not depends on how you
translate ketep he appears in the Book
of Psalms alongside his brother Deborah
the perv encourages readers not to fear
these demons whether that be Deborah
that stalks Into Darkness or keteb that
destroys it midday in Hebrew the word
keteb also means plague and debe means
pestilence so it could also be
translated as you shall not fear
pestilence that stalks in the darkness
or plague that destroys at midday
instead of demons what if this poem is
about disease what if this is a case of
personification where the idea of plague
is given demon-like behavior for
Creative flourish R is for ruach Elohim
speaking of language this next demon
knife highlighted is the Hebrew phrase
ruach Elohim which translates to an evil
spirit of God as we saw with mastema
when God wants to punish someone he
sends a demon to haunt them in the Old
Testament this happens too in one story
an evil spirit of God is sent to torment
King Saul driving him to Madness this
has stumped people for a while is God
responsible for evil after all he gets
demons to do his dirty work it's an
uncomfortable thought we like to imagine
God as all peace and love but in early
biblical texts God is more morally
questionable as time went on people
didn't like the idea of a vengeful God
by the New Testament people placed evil
upon another figure
s is for Satan here we are the big one
the demon of demons Satan in
Christianity Satan is the arch Prince of
evil from tempting Jesus in the desert
to a red multi-headed dragon for the
past 2000 years Satan has been evil
incarnate early Christian thinkers
believe that the snake in the garden of
Eden's story was Satan himself if so all
human suffering can be traced to him
before Christianity however Satan was a
little less well-defined in the Old
Testament book of Job there's a
mysterious character known as the Satan
literally meaning the adversary who
challenges God's judgment a literal
Devil's Advocate but the Satan doesn't
seem to be a bad guy he's just one of
the Angels originally the word Satan
didn't exclusively apply to Angels or
demons it's common for people to be
called Satan's even countries to be
called Satan's everyone's a Satan it
seems that the classic picture of the
devil hadn't evolved by this point Satan
grew into his horns by the New Testament
T is for titibulus over our journey into
biblical demons they seem to Spring out
of spelling mistakes and mistranslations
but who is Behind These errors
introducing to tivolus aka the printer's
devil the patron demon of typos his
specialty biblical errors imagine you
have to write out the King James Bible
by hand that's 783
137 words mistakes are bound to creep in
in fact they often did like in 1631 when
someone accidentally removed a knot from
one of the Ten Commandments Thou shalt
not commit adultery was changed to Thou
shalt commit adultery cheating on your
partner was now permitted of course the
demon titibulus was blamed not the
careless hands of an overworked
bookmaker
U is for unclean spirits unclean spirits
is what the New Testament often calls
demons but what has hygiene got to do
with it all there seems to be an idea
that demons are dirty if they touch you
you are spiritually contaminated this
partly explains the idea of baptism a
literal bath to wash away your sins and
those demons as they say a shower a day
keeps the demons away
V is for vampire Yes you heard me
vampires appear in the Bible well only
once there's a quote in the Book of
Proverbs which says this the vampire has
two daughters give give they cry this
pity sang is not about the reality of
being a vampire Dad instead the two
daughters in question could be a
reference to two thirsty fangs give give
they cry it's either that or the passage
is talking about leeches another
bloodthirsty animal with sharp teeth
regardless this biblical vampire appears
in Jewish folk tales the aluka is a
beast that takes the appearance of a
human but lives entirely off blood when
threatened it will transform into a
fearsome werewolf the question is is a
vampire a demon it depends on how far
you want to stretch the term evil spirit
I suppose W is for witches first
vampires now witches the Bible has a
bunch of rules against the practice of
Witchcraft and divination like Thou
shalt not allow a witch to live these
biblical rules against magic were used
to support the witch trials throughout
Europe and the Americas there was a fear
that witches lived amongst the
population and that they were in cahoots
with demons you'd even get specialized
witch Hunters who'd go around accusing
people of sorcery predominantly older
women these Hunters took the Bible's
laws very seriously the punishment for
witchcraft death
X is for zezbeth zezbeth is one of the
only demons out there beginning with the
letter X zesbeth is from the dictionary
infernal or hell's dictionary a little
catalog of French demons there's not a
lot of information on this one perhaps
for the best zezbeth is the demon of
lies and deceit whether it's a white lie
or full-blown tax fraud zezbeth is
behind it no one knows the origin of
this demon there is an Islamic demon
called al-khadab Arabic thought the liar
but that's pretty much it kadab says
Beth maybe those names are related
somehow or maybe it's all just lies
Y is for Yam it's time for Yam but not
the food the Mesopotamian god of the sea
yam appears in several ancient myths
about Earth's creation these stories
take the form of a giant battle between
yam his giant sea serpent pet and a
heroic God to the Babylonians it was
Tiamat versus Marduk to the ancient
Hebrews it was Leviathan versus L AKA
God once yams Sea Beast is vanquished
the god creates the Earth out of its
body parts German Scholars refer to
these myths as the chaos Camp the
primordial struggle today it's widely
agreed that life began in the ocean so I
can't help but feel a bit sorry for Yam
he doesn't get the respect he deserves
Zed is for zedek the final letter one
that I'm cursed to pronounce as Zed not
Z we've spoken a lot about demons but
not about the Angels appointed to deal
with the demons that get out of hand
enter zedek or Melchizedek the angel of
righteousness his big moment is in the
Dead Sea Scrolls in the war of the sons
of Light against the sons of darkness in
this epic battle at the End of Time
zedek defeats the demon Balia and his
Legions of evil truth happiness and love
abound and the demons are no more a good
place to end this list
26 letters later we've covered biblical
demonology from a to zed it's a ragtag
bunch all from different stories and
eras in time but we can unscramble this
lot and draw out some wider themes you
may have noticed that lots of biblical
demons do not originally come from the
Bible instead they come from the
Apocrypha those books that didn't quite
make it into the Canon it seems that
fallen angels demonic Hitmen and Giants
were too scandalous for mainstream
audiences the Bible itself has a mixed
picture of demons take the Old Testament
for example demons either take the form
of ancient gods like Dagon kemosh and
yam or evil spirits sent from God
himself others like Belial kateb and
Satan were not originally demons just
plain everyday words that became names
over time but then fast forward to the
New Testament writings this had all
changed there's an explosion of demons
Satan becomes a name and exorcisms are
now a thing these Christian writings
were clearly inspired by those
apocryphal books and their Rich
collection of demons from then onwards
demons have been a big part of
Christianity and the abrahamic faiths
scholars of religion believe that demons
offer a neat explanation for the problem
of evil if God is all good where does
evil come from answer demons if
exploring evil spirits in the Bible and
its Apocrypha reveals how these demons
took root and began to grow and evolve
nowadays the study of demons is livelier
than ever before there is demonological
content for every occasion and enough to
fill an entire alphabet
hey thanks for watching I really hope
you enjoyed this one any demons you
think deserve an honorable mention if
you like this video and want to see more
why not subscribe a like and a comment
also go a really long way the channel
recently passed 700 000 subscribers
that's a mind-boggling number and I'm
truly grateful for your viewership
regular visitors of the channel may be
asking where have I been lately well
I've been involved in a very exciting
project I can't tell you what it is just
yet but it will be revealed very soon oh
and do check out the Channel's merch
over at crowdmade we have beanies
t-shirts and hoodies links are in the
description down below
anyway I look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye